two weeks ago Elizabeth Gilbert
excitedly announced her new book this is
a novel set in the mid 20th century in
Siberia and it centers around a group of
people who resisted the Soviet
government and she says try to defend
nature against industrialization
whatever that means it's called the snow
Forest because it takes place in a
forest in the snow that's how she came
up with the title
Gilbert has never been known for
creative titles as for whatever else
might happen in the book I will
personally never find out because I
would never read an Elizabeth Gilbert
book and second nobody will find out
because nobody will read this particular
book she has retracted it she has
retracted the entire book pulled it from
publication and she's done this because
some people were offended that the novel
is set in Russia they are offended that
her fiction novel about mid-20th Century
Freedom Fighters in Siberia takes place
in Russia